these are two victims that are coming  forward but they're choosing to remain  anonymous and I'll tell you why and and  I heard kind of two words here  trafficking and lover boy yeah are those  the main accusations and are they suing  for damages or are they suing to get uh  them arrested so really quickly  um  the survivors are remaining Anonymous  and this was like a last minute decision  a day because of fear  um a fear as a result the legal team is  afraid for their safety  um and that's where we're at I'm in the  United States safety I'm afraid for my  own safety even sitting here speaking  about this  um  so that's where we're at with it um so  we need to make sure before those  survivors step forward uh if they do if  and when they choose because it's always  up to the Survivor you can be a part of  a lawsuit and be a Jane or John Doe  right  um but if and when these survivors  decide to step forward we need to make  sure that they are safe